Thank you all very much, thank you Barbara,  and to everyone for
First inviting me in, second for attending. So I'm gonna try to do something
very difficult
This evening. I'm going to try to put the idea of
The rights, the right to free speech in the broadest possible
historical context. I
want to start with a comment though, you know, we have a an idea built into our
human rights legislation that all the rights are equal in some sense and
that can't be true because
rights conflict with one another and
when things conflict they have to be hierarchically organized and what that means is that there's there's an implication that
there is a hierarchy of rights as well as a hierarchy of responsibilities and that it's also
Incumbent on us to determine the nature of that hierarchy and to determine what constitutes the sovereign
let's say the sovereign right and I would say you might think of that as a modern conundrum that would only
be of interest to
Countries that have formalized Bills of Rights for example, but it's not a new problem
it's an extraordinarily old problem because there's no difference between
Determining the hierarchy of your rights and determining how to live together successfully
It is exactly the same problem one's only articulated in a legal form and the problem of how we should live together
in the most productive possible manner
Everything considered is as old as mankind itself. In fact, I would say far older than that because the same problem
Bedeviled social animals way down the phylogenetic chain. And so this is an unbelievably archaic problem now
years ago when I started
thinking I suppose in earnest I
was trying to address what I later recognized as a postmodern problem and
the problem was
This was in in the late 70s and early 80s when the Cold War was madly raging
Because it peaked in 1962 and it peaked again and in about 1984 thereabouts
and of course at that time people were very terrified about the potential outcome of the Cold War and for
very good reason and I was curious about very curious about this like insanely curious about it it was
Obsessing me I couldn't understand two things. I couldn't understand why the world had divided itself into two
opposing narratives
why that would happen at all and and also why these
Narratives were of such importance to people apparently that we were willing to arm ourselves
Far beyond the teeth and risk
massive mutual annihilation
to battle out the to battle out that conflict between these two ways of looking at the world and I was curious I mean
First the first question was were these merely two ways of looking at the world?
Because you might think well, there's there's no shortage of ways to live in the world
That's a moral morally
Relativistic stance and there's something to that obviously because people different people different
Occupations and they different outlook and and so forth a difficult different political belief
so there's obviously many ways that we can thrive in the world and so some degree of
flexibility with regards to what constitutes your fundamental axioms
Obviously is is necessary
But there's a deeper question and and it is a very deep question
I actually think it's a it's the question at the bottom of the postmodern conundrum, which is whether or not there are any
Reliable meta-narratives. Let's say overarching narratives that can unite people in some fundamental way. And so I was curious
Where were these just two arbitrary ways of looking at the world both?
potentially equally valid and
We're we battling that out because we didn't know when there was no other way to battle it out
Or was there something deeper at stake?
was it possible that one or the other system was correct in some deep manner and I believe I do truly believe that I
entered that
That universe of questions. Let's say with as open as a mind as possible because I actually wanted to find out the answer
you know because well it seemed to me the fundamental question that
Obviously, we fought a whole Cold War about it was the fundamental question. Who was this?
it was the question everyone's my should have been concentrated on and so I
Started to study deeply this this particular question. The first question was well, what were beliefs made out of like what exactly is it?
What is it? What are we talking about when we talk about a belief?
What does it mean that you have beliefs our beliefs structured?
and also that was a
psychological question rather than a political or economic question and that took me a long time to figure out because I didn't know if the
fundamental question was going to be
Sociological or political or or economic or psychological energy turned out to be psychological or perhaps it turned out to be spiritual
that's another way of thinking about it and
If if you could grasp belief
what would constitute a credible belief and what would it mean for a belief to be credible and
I can give you a little a hint about that. I learned this from Jean Piaget that developmental psychologists brilliant brilliant theorists
Genuine genius he was interested in how children organized games and he thought of games the
Organization of games by children as the precursor to adult interaction and he made some very interesting observations about games
You know
especially pretend games which are quite sophisticated because children will get together and play pretend games and what they'll do is
They act out a simulation of the world
maybe they play house they all get together and they cast each other in different roles and then they each act out those rules and
they do that and then in order to simulate something important that they're going to have to adapt to but
Piaget noted a couple of things the first thing, you know, that was that children playing games can play the games in a group
Thank you very much can play a game in a group
But if you take them out of the group and you ask them what the rules of the game are
They don't know they can't
Articulate the rules of the game yet
When you put them together in the group, they can play the game and I thought oh that's just like adults
You see because because well because we wouldn't need a psychology otherwise, right because we'd all be transparent to ourselves already
So what that means is when we all get together and play a game like the one that we're playing in this room, for example
We all can play the game when we're together
but if we brought us out and said well, what are the rules we wouldn't be able to articulate them and
Then I thought well that means that those rules evolved in a real sense
Like they've evolved in a behavioral
Competition and I thought well that's that's a lot like what's happening with animals if you look at how a chimpanzee troop is
Organized or a wolf pack any social animal for that matter going way down the phylogenetic chain
They have to interact with one another in a manner that
That sustains the group because otherwise they all die obviously and that sustains the individuals within the group and offers the individual some
some scope of action and so there's a set of implicit constraints on the manner in which
creatures interact or they don't live and
and
Piaget also came to the same conclusion with regards to children's games. And and this is where he made a distinction. That's so crucial because
Piaget was actually interested in bridging the gap between science and religion. That was his fundamental his fundamental motivation
although very few people know that and he was interested in bridging the gap between
Science and ethics and and he was interested in how ethics evolved as a as a concept and then as a practically applicable
As something that was practically applicable and he made some very interesting comments about games and said well look
What what constitutes a good game?
well one rule is
everybody plays voluntarily
That's a really good game. And then he made another claim which was quite cool
Which was imagine that you had a game a and E and B, and they were competing
against the target and in in game B people were being forced to play and a game eight people were playing voluntarily and
Then you tracked their track record with regards to competitive advantage over time
The game that people were playing voluntarily would win because the people who were playing wouldn't have to waste any effort and enforcement cost
Oh god, that's so smart
It's so smart because because you can see the idea of the emergence of an ethic theory and not an ethic that's rationally constructed
It's an ethic that's actually emerging from the bottom up
Now if the philosopher Friedrich Nietzsche also pointed out that our that our ethic actually emerged from the bottom up it wasn't rational
It wasn't top down. It wasn't enlightenment oriented
Even though the Enlightenment might have codified it
as part of a process of a codification that took place over a very long period of time and so
And then I read other things some say about the way that animals organize the troops. This was later
but but but it's relevant to our talk today that
Primatologist friends to all for example has tried to find out what makes chimpanzee troops stable across time
You know you kind of have this idea that a chimpanzee troop is driven
Let's say by the most dominant powerful male the most aggressive cruel
tyrannical chimpanzee dominates and that isn't what friends do all found what he found was that
In order that those sorts of chimpanzee troops have leaders that meet very violent ends
Because no matter how tyrannical you are as top chimp two chimps 3/4 your size can take you out and they will and chimpanzees are
believably
Unbelievably brutal and very very strong and so tyrannical chimpanzee troops are unstable
It's like that's a major league
Discovery ma'am because it starts to it starts to open up the possibility that the ethic upon which functional states are predicated is far deeper
Than any mere story or any mere
Rationality and that's a really exciting possibility because what it means is that there might be something at the bottom of our ethic
That's really there. It's not just some arbitrary
constructed narrative
it's not just one set of ways to live in the world among many and I would say I would say and I tried to
Outline this partly in twelve rules for life and more in detail in maps of meaning that the evidence on that is already in
Is that there is a there is a convergent ethic that emerges from the bottom-up over
Evolutionary spans of time over millions of years over hundreds of thousands of years over tens of thousands of years as people learn
how to act in a manner that sustains them as
Individuals now and a week from now and a month from now in a year from now
So it has to be iterated that sustains them and their families
Simultaneously that sustains them and their families and their communities across all those time frames
Simultaneously and that's a very very tight set of constraints
And so there might be a very large number of ways to interpret the world as the postmodern set post
Modernists accurately have it but there are not a very large number of ways to exist
Successfully in the world. In fact, it's extraordinarily constrained
it's constrained by the neccessity of playing an
Iterative voluntary game and that's a tight constraint. As any of you who are married know, right?
well, I mean, I mean
I mean
there's absolutely definitively because you see the marriage is a very interesting balancing act because
It has to be good for you, and it has to be good for your wife
let's say but it also has to be good for the two of you and it has to and maybe that's
Superordinate to each of you as individuals and it has to be good for you in that in a way
That's good for your children
And that has to work in society and it has to be something that you can play out moment by moment an hour to hour
And day to day and month to month and week to week and you know
You know perfectly well that there isn't much deviation from the straight and narrow path if you're going to play that game
Because there's just too many ways of falling into trouble and there's way ways of falling into trouble than not falling into trouble
okay, so so that's the first thing so imagine this so this is the this is the idea so
The ethic emerges from the bottom up as we learn how to organize ourselves in ever more complex society sustainable societies
And we don't know what we're doing
Okay, but then what happens is because we're insanely curious and capable of self recognition
We start to tell stories about how it is that we're acting and the stories have two forms
one story is about the structures that we exist in and
That's the stories about other people and every stories about other people, right?
Because we live in a social world and you never see a story. You never go to a movie
You never read a novel that isn't about society and no wonder because that's our environment Society
So stories are about Society and they're about how societies succeed and fail and they're about how individuals within that society
Succeed or fail because what we're trying to do is to watch ourselves and I mean again over the mass of historical time frame
we're trying to watch how it is that we act when we act properly and figure out how to do it as
Individuals and the first way we do that is to code it in stories. That's what stories are for
That's what great literature is for
That's why there are great villains and great heroes and great literature because you want to know how to be a great hero
Unless you want to be a great villain and if you want to be a great hero
You can learn from great villains the opposite of how to act and so you get you get incredible
Incredibly sophisticated
Representations emerging out of that process so that the take on an archetypal form
So for example the the motif of the hostile brothers, which is developed into
Christianity into them between
adversaries of Christ and Satan or Cain and Abel are
The idea of the hero who thrives in the social world and brings renewal to the cosmos
So to speak against the deadly adversary and that's exactly what you need to know and again, it's not arbitrary
It's not an arbitrary set of propositions
It's predicated on the observation of successful and unsuccessful patterns of behavior over very very very very long stretches of time
so there's a behavioral platform and then there's a
narrative
representation of that platform then the two things start to interact because once you have drama and literature
You can learn from drama and literature and alter how you behave and the irr ethic becomes portable
and then what happens after that is that
What happens after that is that thinkers who now have both the behavioural strata and the
representational strata in front of them, right
The procedural ethic the behavioral ethic plus the story
Representation step one step back from that especially after it's written down
this is why white works like the Bible or such critical importance because the the pattern the dramatic patterns are then written down and then
You can step back from them with your consciousness and you can start to analyze them for their for the rule based content you see
That emerging to some degree in the story of Moses
that's actually what's laid out in part in the story of Moses because Moses is leading his people through the desert and
Watching how they fight and watching how they behave and then he has this so it's all very very dramatic. Then he has this tremendous
Revelation, which is this is how we already act
Right. And so what happens is the rules are codified on the basis of the observation of the patterns that are already extent that are
Functional that's a transformation of consciousness at that point
You have your ethic which is far deeper than anything that you can imagine
Start to be articulated out into the body of laws and that's the point at which you have
Let's say true philosophy at the beginning of the body of laws. It's called the body of laws for a reason and so
well, I thought that was all just amazing to have to have to have observed that to think about that bottom-up process and then I
Started reading a lot of religious mythology and I ran across this motif that was developed very in great detail by a Romanian
Murchie le a de who was a great scholar of religions
remarkable remarkable books including a history of religious ideas
which is
Highly recommended book and he talked about this
Interesting motif that I had run across and other writings on mythology and and and in religious stories
which was the Battle of the gods in heaven across time and one of the things Iliad I pointed out was that if you if
You looked at the development of religious system. So say the development of the religious system that came to dominate
Mesopotamia when the Mesopotamian tribes came together imagine each of those tribes had their own God right and then when they came together
That was terribly fractious because you know what happens when different people with different gods get to it's it's ugly
It's ugly and it's no wonder because you know
They all have an ethic and they they're living within the ethic and they're using it to structure their worlds
but the ethics apparently collide and so what happens that the
Civilizational level is that there's constant negotiation and cognitive transformation within the individual populations
But that's represented over the large span of time as a battle between the gods that represent the different tribes in heaven. And so
then what happens across time as all those gods organize themselves into a hierarchy and one God comes out on top and that God is
The supreme god and then this societies like Mesopotamia. Is that Mesopotamia that also happened in ancient Greece?
They assumed that their sovereign is that the person who acts out the sovereign God
Because you might say well where does the concept of sovereignty come from?
Right, if it's not just brute force and it's not his brute force doesn't work. It has to have some other basis
What's the basis of sovereignty? What's the basis of authority not power authority competence Authority, right?
well
How's that played out it's played out by the battle between ethics systems of ethics that are represented in religious language
across vast epochs of time and then the societies of gods
let's say organize themselves into a hierarchy and they have a God at the top and that's actually
Laid right out in the anime ilish for example, which is the oldest
Creation story that we have and out of which it's derived from the same
what would you say cultural substrate is the stories in Genesis, for example, although it represents a variant the the
Mesopotamians had all their gods aggregate themselves together because they were threatened by the unknown
That's what happens in me in the Mesopotamian creation. Myth the unknown gives rise to the gods
They become very fractious and compete and then the unknown decides to destroy them again like God destroying Noah Noah's people in the flood
It's the same basic idea. There's an idea there and the idea is that
We emerge out of the unknown and we're always threatened by it
Not only as individuals but as a group and that means that we need to figure out what it is
That should guide us in order to continually confront the unknown and prevail and so what happens in
Mesopotamia is the gods all get together in a congress and they basically they elect a new God and he new kind of God
His name is marek. By the way, he has eyes all the way around his head and so he pays attention
That's not the same as thinking. It's a different thing attention
It's the same thing the Egyptians
represented and worshiped with the eye of horus the idea that what you should do if you want to survive in this world if you
Want to play a voluntary game that everybody could participate in your bloody eyes better be open
because there are the things that will save you and that's attention and the other thing that mardik didn't he spoke magic words and
so when he spoke the night sky would appear the day sky would appear and so the
Mesopotamians figured out in their great religious story that the fundamental sovereign God was he who pays attention and speaks the truth and
that's something that's something that's
That's not something you punish people for
Right because there's this this is the deepest idea of mankind. It's developed in detail in Genesis in the Old Testament
It's the fundamental idea of Genesis that God uses the logos the word of God to cast
Potential which we all face. That's what we face potentials, right?
You know that you know that the future is unstructured
You have a you have a potential within you that can meet that and there's a potential that
Characterizes the future you meet it with eyes open and with truthful speech
And that's what happens in Genesis because God uses the logos
Which is truthful speech to cast the pre cosmogonic
Potential into habitable order and then he says it's good and there there's a hint there
right because you think well is
habitable order good because life is very difficult and it's a real question whether or not the order that we inhabit is good and the
hypothesis in the Old Testament, is that if
Truthful speech gives rise to the order then that order will be good
And that's really something that like that's really something to apprehend. It's a fundamental
theological
presupposition that the way that you take the potential upon which the cosmos is
Predicated and cast it into the order that allows everyone to thrive is by using
truthful speech
Wouldn't it be something if that was the case and the thing is, you know, it's the case
You know it you know it because you do not admire yourself
If you're deceitful you admire yourself when you have those rare moments in your life where you can actually stand up and say what's true
regardless of the cost and
If you if you give that respect to other people if you treat them as if they're the locale of the divine speech that casts
potential into habitable order
Then they like you maybe they even love you and they get along with you and you could work with them and you can cooperate
With them and you can compete with them. So not only is it the the fundamental axiom that regulates your relationship with yourself?
It's the fundamental axiom that regulates your interactions with other people
And if you do not give them that that honor which is the the presuppositions for their natural
right
Right because you're the idea that you have a natural right is the idea that you have some sort of intrinsic value
If you don't paint treat people as if they have that intrinsic rate, they are not happy with you
Even if they don't know why
because everyone wants to be treated as if
They have free will and as if they confront
potential and as if they're capable of making moral choices and that they should be rewarded when they do things right and perhaps
Punished when they do things wrong, everyone wants that and everyone knows it
And so well, so what does that all have to do with free? Speech well
Yes, everything that's exactly right. So
Free speech isn't free speech. You know people think of free speech is
Kind of like a decoration something like that in your life, and it's not that at all
It's not the ability to speak truth to power. Although it is also that it's not that it's way more than that
Free speech is how you think?
It's not thinking you know that the word that the Genesis relies on to create the cosmos
Let's say in the story
By the way, that's the image of God in which you're made male and female that gives you that fundamental value
That's at the core of our idea of natural right? It's not thinking it's speaking
And the reason for that is look first of all
You can hardly think
It's really hard to think you have to be trained like mad to think you have to be able to divide yourself
Internally into a couple of different
People and then you have to let those people have a war in your head and that means you have to develop
characters who have opinions in
Great detail opinions that might be contrary to your own and then you have to withstand
the tension of letting them have it out and you only see that
Thinking in great literature like you see that in Dostoyevsky
He's an absolute master of that and you know
You can think a little bit but mostly you're biased and you have confirmation
bias
And you see things the way you see them and you have massive blind spots and you're ignorant as hell you just you just you
Just can't think but you can talk and the thing is if you talk other people will correct you
that's the thing and that's
Thinking so if you get up and you have some something to say and you say it stupidly because of course you will because what?
Do you know then other people will tell you where you're wrong and then you can learn right?
And then everybody can think and so what that also means is that to be free to speak
Even to tell the truth means you have to be free to be stupid and ignorant and malevolent and bitter
Because that is who you are. That is what you are cuz you're flawed
So the idea that you know, you can't use your free speech if it's offensive, it's just it's an idea
That is so evident. You don't know if it's naivety. Oh does it's malevolence
It's a real battle which of the which of those two things are worse
I would go with malevolence because it detract some it attacks something. That's so absolutely fundamental
It's like well, of course people who are speaking freely are going to be offensive
I mean, have you ever had a serious discussion with anyone in your life and I mean a serious discussion?
I mean this sort of discussion you have when you're with your wife when you're wondering whether your marriage is going to survive or you
Or with your kids when they've done something that is really not in their best long-term interest
I mean a serious discussion. You can't even get off the ground without being offensive
You can't get off the ground without offending yourself in a conversation like that
You don't even want to admit how you feel or how you think to yourself if you think you can have a difficult conversation?
Without offending people all that means is you're not having a difficult conversation
Because for an easy conversation by definition, no one gets upset about that. There's no real problem. There's no real disagreement
There's and there's no real real world problem to be solved
It's just trivial it's like discussing, you know, last night's sports event
There's nothing to it
If you're going to have a conversation about something that matters
you know in the world made out of what matters that's a good thing to remember if you're going to have a
Discussion about what matters if you're really going to talk about it?
Everyone is going to be offended by that
Especially if there's something rotten in the state of Denmark and you happen to either one in Tripoli that is pointing it out
So then you think well your freedom of speech that's not about you being able to speak truth to power
That's about you being able to chart your destiny in the world and more than that
it's even more than that's important enough because you know life is hard and if you don't get to think
When you when you walk through your life, you will fall into a pit
There's no doubt about that because that's what thinking is for is to stop you from having anymore
Catastrophes that are absolutely necessary and it's a terribly difficult process
And so if if that's interfered with it, isn't that you don't get to speak truth to power
It's that you do not get to act in the world in a manner that allows you to to eliminate
Endless unnecessary hellish suffering and not just for you
But for you and your family and your community and so the enemies of free speech
They're the enemies of the process that turns potential into habitable order
They're our enemies of the Divine Principle and worse. They're their own enemies
right because this isn't well some of us believe in free speech and some of us don't
It's way deeper than that
If you don't believe in free speech you don't believe in the implicit divinity of mankind
You don't believe in the sovereignty of the individual you don't believe in sovereignty as such you're a totalitarian of some sort
Which means you attribute all the divine power to yourself. It's and then we know where that leads, right
It doesn't matter whether it's on the right or the left if we had any sense and we took a look at 20th century history
We know exactly where things go and we could easily choose not to go there
And so when we see someone like reiieve who's imprisoned by a reprehensible?
dictatorship that we have the gall to call our allies then what we see is a
System that's not only hell bent on the destruction of an innocent and good man, but but directly
antithetical to everything that all of us have and there are societies put forward as
necessary to the continual betterment of being itself and so
And I've been so absolutely appalled by the Western world's we need response to the attacks of
Totalitarians upon our freedom of speech the what was done with Salman Rushdie. That was a big big big big mistake, right?
Because it wasn't Rushdie
It was the free speaking artistic tradition of the West and not only of the West right the free speaking
Artistic creative tradition upon which the cosmos is properly established
That's what it was and we all bow down
We all bow down with no resistance whatsoever. It was a massive error
We're gonna pay for that for a very long time. We did the same thing with the Danish cartoons
And you don't want to think about these sorts of things as happening far away
Nothing happens far away when it happened somewhere else is happening right here, too
and that's why we're all here today because we recognize that at least on some level and
We have to stop we need to stop being so naive about our let's say our moral relativism
We need to take a look at history and biology in a very very fundamental way and we need to really understand what our culture
What our culture and and genuine cultures everywhere?
predicated on and that is the idea that the sovereign voice of the individual is the power that casts potential into habitable being and
Restructures tyrannical order when it needs to be restructured
right
And that's what each of us are that's the divine presence in each of us and I do believe that there is no more
Fundamental truth than that, I don't believe that you can date down underneath that. I think that's bedrock
That's the foundation stone of the house
That's the cornerstone of the house and it requires everyone to courageously confront the tyranny
that's them and the unknown that surrounds them and to work for their own benefit and for the benefit of their families and for the
Benefit of their communities and to do everything they can to benefit the world and to live with true speech as the highest value
That's how we sort out the world and we could sort it out
We are sorting it out at a very rapid rate and we could do that much much more effectively
If now I do believe that it's incumbent on us to understand the absolutely fundamental role that these processes take
I know we're here today because we all have at least an intimation of that, right?
We know that there's something about free speech
That's so central that we cannot allow attacks on it to go unchallenged no matter where they occur
But it's very useful to have it articulated and to know that this is bedrock
right
And it's not something arbitrary and it's not a mere game a mere game that we're only playing in the West none of that
It's something it's the most fundamental truth that the human race has ever discovered and we we lose it at our absolute
Peril, and it's not death
It's worse than that the peril
Because there are worse things than death and the worst things than death is hell and we saw plenty of that in the 20th century
And when we let freedom of speech go, that's where we're headed
And unless we want to go there then we should stop aiming for it
So well, thank you very much for the invitation good night.